i'd like to talk to you about the real
reason why we need magnesium now most
people know that magnesium is good for
leg cramps it's good for stress
relaxation
it's good to help you sleep it has
anti-inflammatory properties so if they
have sore muscles they might take some
magnesium
they might even know that it supports
healthy blood sugars and that is one of
the main electrolytes to keep the heart
and rhythm and it works with calcium to
support bone and muscle physiology and
if they've ever watched my video they
know it also supports atp the energy
currency of the entire cell so it's
necessary in producing energy and if you
don't have magnesium you're going to be
tired but a very very important function
of magnesium is to support your arteries
okay especially the inner lining of the
arteries called the endothelial layer
and magnesium is
needed to produce certain compounds
to keep the arteries at a certain tone
magnesium is a potent vasodilator and it
helps other compounds to keep the
arteries soft so they don't get so stiff
also magnesium works with other
compounds to inhibit platelet formation
so this is to avoid thrombosis or a clot
now since the number one cause of death
in the world
is heart disease it might be a good idea
to know a little bit more about
magnesium in fact the fda
recently
allowed a health claim for magnesium so
this is what they allow us to claim
consuming diets with adequate magnesium
may reduce the risk of high blood
pressure hypertension however the fda
has concluded that the evidence is
inconsistent and
inconclusive now of course they need to
say that
because there's so many other variables
involved i mean just by taking magnesium
when you're on a high carb high sugar
diet is not going to do anything so it's
extremely difficult to isolate
the cause and effect relationship with
nutrients
when you have so many other factors
involved especially the diet but the
point is we know
that magnesium has a huge effect on our
cardiovascular system and we also know
that if we're severely deficient in
magnesium
we get
depression
apathy severe cramps and tetany of the
muscle which is that twitching weakness
and even convulsions so that's all
really interesting but did you also know
that 66 of the population
does not even get the minimum
requirements magnesium from their diet
and magnesium levels have been dropping
over the last 50 years
especially in the soils and then in the
plant and then the animals that eat the
plants not to mention that 80 percent of
magnesium is lost when you process foods
and if you look at all the refined foods
you'd be lucky to find any magnesium in
those foods so where do we get magnesium
well guess what magnesium is at the
center
of chlorophyll and chlorophyll is that
green stuff in plants it is responsible
for something called photosynthesis
where plants take light and convert it
into
chemical energy as fuel
carbohydrates as in proteins and in the
photosynthesis process the waste product
is oxygen which is not a waste for us
it's their waste but our benefit but the
question is how much of this chlorophyll
do we actually get in our diets an
average person gets about one and a half
cups of vegetable per day
when we actually need a lot more
especially if we're trying to get
magnesium now we can get magnesium from
grains but of course
they're just too high in carbohydrate so
one of the best sources of magnesium is
leafy greens
anywhere where you have chlorophyll you
can also get magnesium in meats
in nuts and seeds and seafood and even
berries but there's not much magnesium
in dairy products dairy products have
more calcium now if you're deciding to
take a magnesium supplement there are
several forms that i don't recommend one
would be the oxide form another form i
don't recommend is magnesium hydroxide
as well as magnesium carbonate and
magnesium sulfate i don't recommend any
of those forms the forms that are okay
would be like magnesium citrate which is
easily absorbed it's good for cramps
it's good for headaches but one of the
problems if you take too much it creates
a laxative effect another form of
magnesium would be magnesium 3 and 8
which is really good to support your
brain in cognitive functions one of the
cons of that form is that it's very
expensive but that one targets the brain
another form that i like is called
magnesium bis glycinate now many times
people want to know what's the
difference between magnesium
glycinate versus magnesium glycinate
well the answer is there is no
difference they're both the same now the
reason i like this form is that it's
very easy to absorb
it's good for cramping it's good to help
support healthy blood sugars it's good
for stress it's good for relaxation it's
good to help you calm down and it
doesn't have the laxative side effects
that many other forms have and the amino
acid that they use to formulate this
compound glycine
has its own benefit of
supporting sleep decreasing daytime
sleepiness and making you feel really
relaxed and if you want more information
about that type of magnesium i put a
link down below then we have magnesium
orotate this one's really good for pro
athletes it improves energy but this one
is also very expensive as well but if
you're an athlete this one might be the
one that you want to take then we have
magnesium taurate magnesium taurid is
really good if you have blood sugar
issues if you're a diabetic
that's the one i would recommend and
lastly we have magnesium malate which is
really good to support
fibromyalgia so now you know more about
magnesium
now i think would be appropriate for you
to watch this video on calcium check it
out
you